hi i'm john boyega and this is the wired
auto complete interview
[Music]
now these people are really googling out
here
what is john boyega
do i reveal
known for i feel like i'm known for
attack the block to some people and star
wars to most because i've done a little
a little film called star wars it was an
indie low budget
not not a lot of funding and yeah but a
lot of people know it for some reason so
i say star wars what is john boyega
doing now well right now i'm doing press
for three movies breaking the woman king
and they clone tyrone but in my free
time i'm going on dates i'm going
go-karting spending time with friends
and going to parties
what is john boyega's next movie i
actually don't know i'm kind of waiting
for these three to come out so someone
can see it and then give me a job next
year honestly that's just how it works
guys you just gotta do projects everyone
sees it and then the next year but the
savings are correct i've got enough in
the savings
john boyega what's in the box oh
all right we need to do a part two to
this me and gwen right i think that's
what everyone's referring to yeah me and
gwen done this silly you know silly show
called what's in the box where we had to
basically put our hands in a box and
feel lizards spiders and all different
types of critters good times i miss you
gwen
what school did john boyega go to i went
to an amazing school called westminster
city for boys
i didn't like
second at what we call it secondary
school you like call it high school i
didn't i didn't enjoy it i didn't enjoy
it i enjoyed college i enjoyed
university and i enjoyed primary school
prior to that but high school for me was
like i have no money i couldn't afford
the sneakers that everybody had i didn't
have the
you know the clothes to fit in and stuff
so i was just like
but then it got to college
college is when i sprout
[Music]
does john boyega i'm getting worried now
does john boyega have tattoos yeah i do
i didn't show them much i've had tattoos
for a long time people i just yeah i
just wasn't showing them a lot so
whenever people see my arms they're like
oh but yeah i have
a few tattoos yeah this is um a tattoo
that i got in representation of my
sisters my two older siblings blessing
and grace and then my love for wolves
and horse riding the synergy and family
is so important to me and wolves
naturally have that synergy and family
obviously their role in packs but the
love between them my siblings blessing
grace and john are represented by three
cubs with one wolf with their breath
going into a horse i design all my
tattoos i sketch in and draw and give it
give it to the eyes so it's just
something like a binding tattoo to
remind me of the love between me
blessing you know and grace my two my
two older sisters who i love daily i
love you and when you love getting yours
because i'm sick and tired of being the
only one
does john boyega have
an oscar i do
i have an oscar isaac
what's the
the most meaningful
so far is my statue at madame tussauds
that is is cool and i've been seeing
some pictures people uploaded and going
to see this the wax figure that's been
real cool does john boyega
watch anime yeah i do
i watch attack on titan i watch naruto i
watch uh one piece uh i'm on demon
slayer right now which is that which i'm
enjoying i definitely think the style of
storytelling for anime is is something
that other genres can't particularly
catch up i think that's what anime is
for you know i think anime also the
story the story sometimes a lot of these
stories last over 10 years like you're
with one character for a long amount of
time apart from tv it's very hard to see
that kind of content out there too also
it's the seriousness and depth in anime
it's 2d but
you have emotions for the characters as
if they actually uh they have oxygen and
blood running through their veins so
it's it's a unique style of storytelling
that i really really love and a lot of
people do too does john boyega work out
at the moment no
no i want this belly to hang off a
little bit i realized
soft
and muscular a little bit of dead bod a
little bit of lean and that's what i'm
on right now and then when i get a roll
that requires me to be like spider-man
you know get that tom holland body going
on then i'll change but right now i'm on
a break did i agree that you had some
unusual names for the equipment
dumbbells chicken drumsticks the plates
call them pizza stacks you know it's p
you know when you see a pizza stacked on
top of each other i recognize that if i
go to the gym calories has to be a part
of my workout in some way because i
really like eating and i sometimes hate
dying so i just call the equipment
that's meant to make me look good
food that i like so pizza and drumsticks
and the barbells i call lollipop because
you know
you know i mean
but that's just me guys i'm weird like
that
all right all right this is what people
are googling who john boyega what people
just don't fill out the the words who is
john boyega why did the person google
this they what they had seen me and then
was like oh who is oh yeah yeah they
probably saw me in the trailer said who
is that well hi guys i'm john i'm an
actor i'm a producer and i'm just a
young 30 year old man
who does john boyega play in star wars i
will act as if i'm not slightly offended
by that question but i play a guy called
finn fn2187 who's a stormtrooper turned
rebel
if you haven't watched it now bloody l i
think people under-appreciated his
lineup in episode nine if you recognize
episode seven and eight finn's hair he
had no lineup nine i got that sorted for
you guys and then no one gave the
character props for that so i i have a
problem they didn't appreciate his
hairstyle who does john boyega support
mum dad wait wait is this financial
support is this just moral in that
[Laughter]
i support a whole bunch of people i
support some young people through via
converse in my filmmaking scheme i
support some young people at domino
taylor center down in the uk done a few
you know charities and stuff and then i
financially support mom and dad mom dad
just send me the email when you want me
to you know buy you something who is
john boyega dating going on a few dates
actually i've actually i have time to
actually go out on dates and go on
dinners
went to one yesterday nailed it let's
see if i get a you know a second one see
how she feels i'm gonna i'll let you
guys know on the next next interview but
she was she was fine
what i like about being single is that
you're given the time to do the the work
the individual work to you know work on
yourself get yourself in order get your
mind right you have the you know the
freedom to do for self which i think is
important
all right is john boyega is john boyega
in kenobi no definitely not in kenobi
because finn is not alive in terms of
the uh the canon and the timeline i love
it i love everyone i've been loving it
i've been having fun with that i think
it's cool i like the fact that hayden is
back which is fun to see my guy anakin
you know anakin's one of my faves so i'm
enjoying it
is john boyega nigerian
what kind of question is that
okay now see the back of my head the
shape of my head so you cannot tell when
it's when we got a nigerian brother i'm
definitely nigerian actually i have dual
citizenship so i have a passport in the
uk and i have a possible in nigeria
since birth so yeah i'm a fully nigerian
yeah
is john boyega still acting
who the hell put this in
absolutely a lot of people do ask me
that though and i understand because it
takes us a long time to film the
projects but just remember guys before
we bring out the projects i have to film
them so it took me two years to film
these three projects that come out this
year so yeah it takes a long time but
yeah i am i am still acting thank you
for asking
is john boyega nice yeah yeah of course
yeah nice can't be starting no problems
you know if you start a problem with me
however
but
in general i'm not saying i'm cool
welcome
[Music]
how john boyega
how to pronounce john boyega john
boyer
bodega
but then just add that why for everyone
in new york how old is john boyega i
just turned the big three o but
obviously fan boy no pimple young face
and then you can look like you're still
in your 20s like me
thinking in my 30s
well i'm saying in my 30s like i've been
here for a minute but in terms of just
getting here and the information i've
been hearing from a lot of other 30 year
olds that i've been kind of like
listening to you do things more on
purpose you know you have much more of
an intuition about what you want and and
i'm looking forward to that more and
more how did john boyega become
an actor from primary school i did
performing arts stuff and i wasn't good
at much else i tried football it was all
social circles i tried to get into the
football group couldn't do that i tried
to be a part of the highly academic
group you know the a-star students
couldn't do that tried to be part of the
nerds got too bored couldn't do that
then i saw the performing arts people
doing contemporary dance and tap and
they accepted me and i said oh
i'm a theater kid so i joined that group
and then from there i got a cool
opportunity with a scholarship to
theater pekka so i'm quite lucky i was
helped
did i believe that your first role was
like there's a leopard first of all i
don't like the way you asked that
question as if that isn't one of my you
know most known roles this is uh
obviously i'm very famous for my first
role my starring role actually as the
leopard in the nancy spider-man stories
which is based off of the old folktale
jamaican books i played the leopard
which is uh
you guys want to see this his turn in
this is
it's ridiculous i would say better than
anything i've done before and that star
wars included all of them you know my
first gig
how tall is john boyega i've always
wanted to answer this guys it is 5 10 i
reached the average all these five
sevens five sixes and eights that i've
been hearing about is not true five ten
i reached the average and if i
straighten up my back i can even get
more apart from that i'm i feel like i'm
a good person so hopefully uh my height
doesn't stifle anything
all right that's it guys obviously i'm
so shocked to hear that you guys are so
intrigued by me and i'm thankful for
your continuous support anyway next time
wired
[Music]